russ it's a second straight game that
you've received booze after you know a
turnover
is that a hard experience for you i mean
this is this is home for you and like
coming back was a special thing is that
is that is that a hard thing for you to
absorb in any way sign of respect
signing respect i don't
um
[Music]
my
mindset and
how i think about this game and
what i'm able to do for this game is not
predicated on booze
i have a platform that i'm able to use
to be able to do other things that god
has blessed me with to be able to do and
i will continue to do those things
regardless of people booth with me cheer
for me
cuss me out call me names it doesn't
really matter
the most important part is that i
continue using
my gift to be able to play basketball
and use that platform to be able to help
and
other people
around the world and that's all
i can do and
that's it specifically for this team
like the goals that this team has does
that
reflect in a certain way on on on how
this
has gone and how this experience has has
come together
yeah i mean
as it pertains to the team i mean the
team is not getting booed so
you asked about for me that's all i can
actually respond about myself and
what i'm able to do to be able to
mentally stay in the right place enjoy
being home and joy
have an opportunity to be able to
see my kids take them to school every
morning
see my family mom and dad and my close
friends every day and i don't take that
part for granted basketball is a short
time in your life
and i enjoy it and have fun and
want to compete at the highest level but
also it's not the end-all be-all
and
there's something that bigger than
basketball that we can do as people and
i understand that so that's why i'm
comfortable with
whatever comes cheers booze doesn't
really matter
russ you told bt that
searching for consistency could perhaps
help with the challenges and obviously
nba trade deadline this week there's a
lot of activity today yeah
would
the roster
making some sort of deal would that
make things harder in terms of
consistency
you know honestly david i'm not sure you
know that's out of my hands front office
you know they'll figure out the best of
what they can my job is to make sure i
come to work uh do my job to the best of
my ability um and that's all i can do
russ i guess sticking on the consistency
front uh frank has said he's still
looking for to find kind of a starting
lineup and he's obviously been kind of
tweaking that game to game recently um
what's that like for you guys as the
starters to kind of be playing with with
different lineups out there and see it's
difficult difficult you don't never know
when you're coming in you never know
when you're coming out you never know
when you're playing you never know
a bunch of things um and i'm speaking
for me personally um so
it's a difficult process to be able to
figure out in creating a rhythm creating
some consistency where we can actually
see what we're able to do as a team but
those decisions are made by him and his
coaching staff and
you know
got to live with it and move on
russ um there's a moment right before
the end of the game where you went over
to lebron and a.d on the bench um peta
lebron on the head a.d on the shoulder
seem like you're trying to pick them up
in that moment um
can can you kind of take me through this
encouragement just
keep your head up keep playing tough
night
um
and i told them i wish i could help them
unfortunately i wasn't in the game to be
able to help them um and that's why i
was you know i came in a bit to help
them out so unfortunately
i haven't been able to do that you know
for them but that's not my call um i can
be there um
you know as a leader
and as a voice of whatever it is that is
needed for the team and that's what i'll
do
um until
you know
my number or whatever is called during
that time just because i i don't want
your words to get misinterpreted or
twisted i want to be clear about this
um
has frank been clear enough with you
about when and when you're not going to
play
and has that been a problem
he hasn't um but that's i don't i don't
need him to be clear about
whether he makes whatever decision he
makes and that's so that's up to him my
job as a professional is to come to work
um being a positive mindset
put my head down do my work to the best
of my ability and be there to encourage
my teammates
that's it
do you have a sense for
what benchmarks you have to hate
to to be in the starting line or the
closing lineup more consistently
um
i'll get that answer for you brother i
wish i did i shouldn't have to hit any
benchmark to be honest i put a lot of
work in i got a lot of respect in this
game i i don't have to hit a benchmark i
shouldn't have to um i earned the right
you know to be
and close the lineups i mean uh
you know
numbers will tell you
i don't have to explain that but like i
said once again it ain't my decision
that's the decision that he
and
the staff think is best for the game and
unfortunately um you know
just kind of just gotta go with it and
figure it out the best way i can and be
there for my teammates as much as i can
and make sure i come to work and do my
job as a professional